yang speaks is sponsored by expressvpn
protect your online privacy today at
expressvpn.com
[Applause]
yang
i want to move people in telling stories
to be fired up to take action which is
why
you talk about like how dire things are
but you also give everyone hope you have
a vision of what society could be if we
can tap into our humanity
and i feel like what you're doing with
this human-centered storytelling is
trying to drag us
in this direction i feel like the world
needs much much more of it the world
would use like could use like a legion
of cheryl housers even though that's
impossible
because you're like this unique figure
and unicorn
and one of my goals and having this
conversation really was for you to try
and impart some of what makes you
you want to like other folks who want to
be you
[Music]
it is my pleasure to welcome to yang
speaks award win winning filmmaker
uh and human storyteller extraordinaire
cheryl hauser cheryl welcome thank you
andrew
i'm uh thrilled to be here with you and
cheryl you and i go way back um where
first i'll take uh listeners
to the beginning of the campaign there
was this video that that sort of
launched the campaign
um it was uh me saying i'm andrew yang
and there were robot arms uh
and graphics around universal basic
income
and i loved that video at the time
and i now realized just what an
extraordinary
filmmaker you were because you didn't
have much to work with during that time
like there was like the campaign as we
know it today didn't exist so there were
there was no footage
of crowds there wasn't even me
really interacting with folks and so you
had to work some real magic
i'm not sure how many people
listening to this remember that first
campaign launch video because
no one was paying any attention
but thank you for taking that challenge
on like i thought you aced it at the
time and now i appreciate it even more
well thank you um it was a challenge
mostly because i'm such a visual
storyteller and i like
telling stories um film is a
you know it's all about capturing action
um and there was
really no action we could capture with
you because you hadn't declared yet
you weren't out interacting with people
also you're all about humanity first and
i couldn't capture you with
other people and that's what humanity is
all about
so um we did film with you and then had
to
um license some of the footage to to
bring some of what you were saying
alive and that was very painful because
i love
i love capturing original footage and
capturing really beautiful original
footage
but you know what i i you know as a
filmmaker
filmmaking is problem solving and it's
all about okay how do we tell the story
and how do we tell it with what
we have to work with right now and i you
know your message came through loud and
clear and so did your humanity and
that's what
that's what mattered now one reason i
wanted to
have this conversation with you is
because i feel like
there are a few things happening um one
is that
uh so much of the way we communicate now
is through stories
uh and that's from folks trying to
promote something on their social media
to politics for sure all the way up to
documentary films and
i found it both frustrating but also
edifying that it seems like politics is
really
becoming very much about storytelling uh
it's about trying to
message um your policy in particular
ways
and i feel like people could use like a
primer on effective storytelling which
is sort of what i wanted you to
to come and talk about because there's
just a lot of bad stuff out there and i
know you're
you're a seasoned pro so when you see a
video you're like oh this is not very
good
about a lot of things but what i kind of
wanted
to do is for you to lay out for someone
who's passionate about something
maybe it's about a candidate or a cause
or really about how they can
most effectively uh convey
um their excitement in an effective way
using
let's call it um video as a medium and
now i'm not talking like you know
hour-long video i'm talking about right
now
i suppose in this era it's more likely
to be like a 60-second video
sure um i believe strongly in
human-centered storytelling
i mean it's not only what i believe in
it's what the science
tells us is what's most effective and um
i i use storytelling as a driver to
create understanding break down biases
uh create connection between people um
and especially now more than ever
um you know when we're becoming more and
more polarized to show that what we have
in common is so much as as human beings
so much greater
than what separates us i mean and and to
use storytelling to
not just create understanding but also
to drive action
so um and solidarity but um so
so i you know for for anyone who wants
to
reach others uh it's important to
um to understand who you want to reach
and then to
um cast people who are relatable
to whoever you're speaking to um and
bring
uh viewers on an emotional journey
through that person
so casting people on their social media
their casting is just going to be
so if it's themselves it's about being
uh vulnerable being authentic being
genuine
uh people really can pick up
when someone isn't now when when you're
as good a liar as our president is he
comes across as to some people is
authentic but but most people
when they're putting putting on a show
and not being genuine people sense that
um and that's one of the reasons why you
were so popular andrew you were very
real you were yourself um you were
vulnerable
you were fallible you were you know and
you
you started out a bit uh the robotic the
numbers guy
not accessing as much your humanity and
that was
something you grew into as you became
more comfortable on the campaign trail
it was always there
um so you know i i guess
i'm not here to ask you questions but um
but
yeah but but even in terms of of um
of your learnings on the campaign trail
um what did you
experience as what resonated most with
people
about you
well we had a joke on the campaign trail
where we're going to start with people's
heads and then move to other body parts
i think that that was true about me too
uh where when i started out i thought
okay we've got this massive problem that
i can see
um in automation and transformation the
economy i have facts and figures that
i've
researched and have confidence in and
conviction
in uh and so let me try and communicate
this to
folks and it was
effective with some narrow band of
people um certainly not like this
whole swath of people which i think i
expected
uh and and then and you always pushed me
on this too because you were with the
campaign in the early days and then
um as we progressed where you thought
that we needed to make more emotional
appeals
and i'll say for me it was a struggle
because
that's not that wasn't my natural mode
of trying to communicate
or deliver a message you know i i
been the ceo of a private company and
i was very seldom
burying my soul or tugging on my heart
strings in that role
you know it was like okay here's the
goal here's what's going on
here are numbers here's the the best
approach let's go do that
and we tried to have fun like i tried to
be fun uh
but a lot of the time it was um just
about trying to get
specific actions done uh so it was a lot
of learning for me
cheryl and did i expect that learning
from the beginning
i think i underestimated it i think i
underestimated the humanity involved
in running for president which might
sound ridiculous if you say that
but i i believe it's true of me
well you always had that humanity i mean
i you know the
movie we did together generation startup
uh it's there and
uh when we traveled across the country
together
at event screenings very present um
but um and you certainly grew into it
um it's funny you talked about you know
in generation startup you're yoda and on
the campaign trail you were luke
skywalker
um in generation startup so let's give
well but to finish your your question i
i mean it's it's basically i think
people have to be
themselves genuine authentic human and
then
um uh take viewers on an emotional
journey and that can be on
on an emotional journey around them why
they're running
why they care about the issues they care
about or
through other people
all right this podcast is brought to you
by unagi scooters
i have one of these and i ride around in
new york
and i love it it's pretty fast
it's not that heavy which is great i
mean it's well built but
you can fold it and carry it upstairs or
uh for me i've got a two-floor walk-up
but i can take out my stairs pretty
easily it charges fast it lasts for a
while
i look kind of ridiculous in some ways
but in a good way because i'm
kind of tall and awkward riding this
thing but it's fast it's awesome i
freaking love
this thing cnet actually rates it says
the best all-around electric scooter so
it's not just me saying how awesome it
is the pros actually think this thing's
great too
so unagi scooters has an awesome
discounts for you and you can get yours
at unagiscooters.com so that's
u-n-a-g-i-scooters.com
and act now with the discount code yang
and get 150
off the unagi e500 so don't hesitate
this thing was the best decision i made
in kovid's i don't have to ride public
transportation
i don't have to ride on the subway i
don't have to take the main train i can
ride my scooter anywhere
unagi scooters.com use the discount code
yang
[Applause]
when you came to me i guess it was uh in
january or february
um when you were gaining some traction
but not
it hadn't broken out widely yet and you
said cheryl what can you make for me
that that that captures my humanity
and our slogan humanity first and that's
when i said to you
we need to find people who embody
the need for your policies who are
brimming with humanity
and we used you as product placement in
those spots i mean you
we so we filmed with two people a man
and a woman
they had certain issues problems they
were struggling with and then
um uh you know we the
we captured them in a way that uh they
were very
relatable universally relatable even
though they were
very unique in particular in their um
identity and stories
and then you came in as kind of the
savior who with your policies
would change their lives so we showed
not tell i mean it's also really
important
in storytelling especially in film a
visual medium
it is show not tell people don't take in
information
or they take it in much better if it's
the information is in service to
a story that uh touches their hearts and
um so the you know science tells us that
the most effective storytelling
is one one that um is is
is human-centered around people people
we care about we identify with we relate
to
um and um we release oxytocin
when we watch something about someone we
care about and that is
the love hormone it it's it's what makes
us
um feel um attracted to somebody it's
it's the hormone we secrete when we kiss
when we breastfeed when we have sex when
we hug when
when we like videos of our kids as like
the ones
exactly you feel warm and fuzzy it
actually changes
your body chemistry and then the story
needs to be structured in a way where
there's some
tension and rising tension and
if so that's what captures our attention
and holds our attention because we
secrete cortisol
and cortisol is um it's a hormone that
is from our um the amygdala the fear
center and
um it's what what um heightens our
attention
um so if you have rising tension in a
story
and you have people who are relatable
the cortisol grabs the attention keeps
your attention because
i mean we're in an attention starved
world but even before social media and
all these other things our brains
are prone to wonder but you want someone
engaged
so it engages our brains it engages our
heart
and then after if if i believe strongly
in structuring stories that well the
classic story structure
from like ancient times to today is
there's someone that person has a goal
there are obstacles in the way the
person has to struggle to reach the goal
we have to understand what's at stake
the bigger the stakes the harder it is
to reach the goal the more we
identify with the person and root for
them the more we go
on that emotional journey with them
which is actually um
if you if you study people's brains when
they're hooked on a story
they actually their brains um act like a
participant
not a spectator so you can actually
bring someone on an emotional journey
and then if you end on triumph they
reach the goal
you leave your viewer feeling wow i can
do that too
um and then it also releases dopamine
which is kind of the reward
center from the reward center of our
brain so it leaves us feeling optimistic
and hopeful
so um that's that is like so it sounds
like you start with oxytocin
and then you get to cortisol and then
you hope to leave them with dopamine
right but you and the way to do that is
to
um tell stories about somebody
the viewer cares about whether it's the
candidate
uh telling his or her own personal story
where we care about the person um and
that person's struggle it could be
personal struggle it could be
struggle of why they care so deeply
about
why they're running or a certain issue
and then
ending with a sense of hope because if
you
leave people with no hope then they're
not going to feel
like they should take any action because
if they're not going to be able to
achieve
their goal then why bother
you know you want to and which is so
one of the criticisms you know i had and
like i struggled with
we've all seen those cheesy political
ads it's like you know it's a black and
white photo
and it's like i grew up like uh you know
the the
son of a cobbler or like that like that
the daughter of a um thatcher or what
you know i mean i make that up because i
don't think we have thatchers anymore
but
it's like like where where you make the
person relatable
and then like you make it seem like they
overcame this hard scrabble
background and then like you have some
uplifting photos of them
you know like i personally have lost
patience for
uh those political ads and i know when
you and i
talked about this stuff like i i
struggled a little bit with trying to
convey
things in a way that felt personal to me
that just didn't feel like
artifice or it's like okay hit this beat
he hit that beat
because i feel like at this point people
have just lost all patience with
political
ads and communication but it sounds like
the things you're saying appear in a lot
of these political ads so
do political ads look the way they do
because they work
well i don't i don't know but i think
that execution
it's always the devil is in the details
right it's
like what i'm laying out you can like
any story you can execute
well or you can execute poorly so like
cheesy's horrible out there like yeah it
sets out to make a bad movie but there
are a lot of bad movies that get made
sure and it's not pink by numbers it's
not
like there's no formula to follow it's
really about for every single person
finding what is most genuine to them
um but that doesn't mean cheesy and
cheesy cheesy is how something
shot it's the music it's the graphics
it's
cheesy is um you know it's a quality
and so i think that um
uh you you know you you want
the um the feeling of a video to reflect
the identity and feeling of the
candidate
not to because everything again this i i
hate
the word authenticity because it's so
overused
but like you that is one of the many
reasons andrew why you broke out because
you
didn't you didn't study what do other
politicians do and how do people
running for office how how am i supposed
to behave
you didn't do that you were you you
always showed up as you
um well one thing that we found uh early
in the campaign when we were shooting
various videos
or appeals where the most effective
appeal
was just me talking to my cell phone
camera
i think because of what you're
describing where it strikes people
as very genuine and human
because everyone talks about their
phones and so
uh it seemed like you couldn't fake
anything and i think that
that's something i've seen with younger
political figures
yeah where they seem really good at that
right you know i i'm not sure how
excellent an instagram soliloquy
deliverer i
am uh you know in the scheme of things
like uh but i
i agree that just giving someone a
glimpse into
your moments on the trail or your uh
you know like home or whatever it
happens to be
like it makes them feel like they know
you in a particular way
i think if a politician was not able to
do that
um then it seems like there's something
missing
well i you know aoc's launch uh video
was brilliant
um it wasn't hugely polished but that
didn't matter
i mean in terms of how it was shot it
actually probably was helpful that it
felt so real
um and it was it was everything i just
described in terms of
you know uh her her struggles her
journey her why
her you know her her being relatable but
it was you know um not cheesy there was
nothing
cheesy about that video so it's it's all
about the execution um
and and people being vulnerable being
themselves i mean
you know you you sealed even studies
about
leadership and what builds trust and
what builds loyalty
among a leader it's if that person has
credibility
and then that person is vulnerable
and and and shares that they're fallible
or that they're scared about something
or that you know shares
human emotion that we all have
then people see that person as human not
superhuman you don't want to be seen as
superhuman
because then you don't seem approachable
you don't seem real most people probably
would like to be seen as superhuman
[Music]
this episode of yank speaks is brought
to you by our friends at expressvpn so i
didn't know anything about
vpn before i connected with expressvpn
and this podcast um and i got to try it
out for free
like you can with our with our code and
it's
it's amazing it's literally seamless to
what you're normally doing in terms of
browsing the internet but you know that
you're secure you know that people don't
they're not taking your cookies not
taking your info they have no idea where
you're coming from which is great
the other day i watched um that movie
inside man
with denzel washington clive owen
and jody foster forgot shoes in that
movie and the movie was amazing
total badass movie and i watched it on
vpn
um and i couldn't tell the difference
between it didn't slow down my
connection in
any sort of capacity um so expressvpn
keeps all of your information secure by
encrypting 100 of your data
with the most powerful encryption
available and you guys got to check it
out
so protect your online activity today
with the vpn rated number one by cnet
and wired visit our exclusive link
expressvpn.com and you can get an extra
three months free
on a one year package that's e-x-p-r-e
yang expressvpn.com to learn more
when you're starting out particularly if
you're running for office as i was
um you do feel some sort of pressure to
be
competent and not super vulnerable shall
we say
uh and um there there came a point in
the campaign where i became increasingly
comfortable with the fact that
i could have vince some degree of
vulnerability or struggle and not have
people just say like oh like you know
this person's
like not serious or not presidential or
whatever it is i mean president is
uniquely
tough because there was this struggle to
quote unquote seem
presidential
and then so when i just joked about like
most people would like to be seen as
superhuman
um is that that i think and even if you
have the reverse of it too it's like
if for example the first image you see
of a candidate or a social media story
is of the person struggling and you
don't know them or don't
like have a sense of them then like i
like there's a concern that it'd be
um more of a turn off than like a reason
to try and get behind someone
like if i'd never seen a candidate
before the first thing i saw was them
talking about how hard it was i'd be
like
like i'm not sure if i necessarily would
uh buy in or
am i wrong about all of this it's a good
question i mean andrew when you cried
on the campaign trail after one of those
school shootings and you got up
to give a speech and you broke down in
tears
you know everybody fell
the ones who were in love with you
already fell more madly in love with you
and you picked up so many supporters at
that moment
and um i think that a lot of people who
were moved by that
were had not been aware of you prior to
that
so you know had you been a woman and you
cried
i think it might have backfired so there
are some gender issues
yeah so that that's that you know that
that's an excellent point
but um i you know when you
i when you posted your somebody found or
you
know you posted your your high school or
something something
you're getting out of new york magazine
and then i had to be like well this is
coming out anyway so i
posted something from your yearbook in
goth
like you know people went wild on social
media
because you know that you were human you
were relatable
you were you know what you just said
about uh gender though i think is really
interesting and this
is something that zach said to me on the
trail too
um where if you do something against
type then people
um like it so you know
if i'm supposed to be the asian tech
entrepreneur um and then i cry because
there's a grieving mom who tells
tells me about how her uh three-year-old
or four-year-old was shot in front of
her
uh and then that's like not what you'd
expect so then people like oh it's like
a third dimension
where is it you just said it like if you
were if you had a woman
and she acted emotional in the same way
and she cried
uh then you might not uh
interpret it favorably because you're
because it's not necessarily quote
unquote like against type i don't know
if that's
um if that makes sense or is right
uh i think i
i think what it boils down to truly is
how
genuine the person is you know if
somebody
turns on the faucet and cries because
it's a manipulative move i'm gonna do
this because i think people will find me
uh sympathetic it's you know horrible
but
i mean you you were so i keep saying
this you were so
genuine and that's you know when you
when you said i kept thinking how do i
be presidential
you actually you didn't you didn't
care that much about being presidential
you didn't care about running your
campaign
like everyone else did you didn't wear a
tie on that first
debate because right you know or well
after that you couldn't wear one after
that i mean you know
but you know it it's it's it's you know
it's i don't think you over
thought like uh you were like this is
who
i am and i'm gonna be me
and so and people felt that they felt
that here's somebody who's not a
politician they were so relieved
that you were not a politician and that
you cared deeply
and you know so
in terms of you know when when we did we
did that video together with joe lamar
and um in the edit room
i chose to open that video with him
weeping
you know he's this big guy what six
three six five covered in tattoos
looks looks you know everyone looks at
him and thinks he's a gangster which is
horrible stereotyping
but we're you know i filmed with him and
he's there weeping
about how he's working two jobs getting
three hours of sleep a night
even working two jobs can't make ends
meet
um and uh at the end of the video
you know the comments on the social
media and also on the eight-minute
doc were extraordinary people saying
how much they admire joe the solidarity
they felt with joe how strong
joe is that you know so people saw joe
as
as super strong they did not see him as
weak even though we opened that video
with him crying
so i joe joe's an amazing guy um
but i agree with you i think that um
maybe as
uh a person who was in that boat it's
like sort of harder to embrace
that sort of thing but i agree with you
that most people would find it appealing
and human so on on this this topic i
think some people are probably curious
as to how you came to be a storyteller
like what's the what's your
story in terms of your um doing this
work
and obviously i know a lot of your
backstory but i think
like some people listening to this would
be like how does someone become
like um an award-winning filmmaker and
how did you get to to this stage so when
i was
in college i worked on a feature
documentary called children of darkness
about children with mental illness and
we were a tiny team we were three people
the the
director cinematographer and me um and
uh they were older men at this point
cheryl you were i was 19.
and so i spent my days in these
psychiatric wards with young children
and i was you know getting to know the
kids and getting them to open up and
finding their stories
um and sometimes interviewing them on
film because they had formed that trust
and bond with me
um and then you know learning from uh
you know these two amazing filmmakers
and came out of college and um worked
in feature films as a producer um was
one of the producers on
um and and children of darkness was it
was a heart-wrenching film to make it
was nominated for an academy award
um the filmmaker the director died young
and
his sister put it up on youtube 10 years
ago it has an
astronomical number of views which is
extraordinary for a 35 year old
movie um but um then
you know came out of college and moved
into producing and was one of the
producers of david o'russell's first
movie spanking the monkey and
was making films out in hollywood um and
then started having kids and didn't want
to be in la all the time so i moved into
non-fiction television so you moved to
la directly out of college you have no i
stay i
i moved to london directly out of
college and
i worked with robert bolt who wrote dr
chivago lawrence of arabia man for all
seasons
and won many academy awards and he had
had a stroke
and he was um
writing the mission and i did all the
historical research for the mission
and worked with him in an adaptation of
a gorby doll novel
and i got that job because of a trait
that i use in everything i do now which
is
very active listening um
i went and met with him and he uh was
very hard to understand
because he had this stroke and i
i listened with my like whole body and
core
and i think he felt relaxed and he felt
i could see and hear him
and that we could communicate and he
hired me to do all the research and we
grew very close
um and then when i moved back from
london
i um started producing feature films in
new york
but was in la all the time because
that's where
that world is and then when i had my
first child whom
you know avery i didn't want to be
traveling so much so
i moved into non-fiction television when
that was um
just coming of age and made hundreds of
hours of television
for nat geo discovery channel and all of
the cable channels
and was always second in command
building the company for other people
but i got to an
agent stage about 10 years ago where
i felt that um i had uh
tremendous talents that i could be using
for
uh more meaningful work and i finally
got up the courage to go out on my own
and launched creative breed with the
mission
one to only tell stories that would
inspire me and inspire other people
and uh lead to positive
social action or or positive action good
juju
in the world and then only only work
with people who
aligned with my values um because
those two things are super important to
me so now i
tell human-centered stories across all
platforms the feature documentary we did
together generation startup to you know
web series
national campaigns um branded content
but all with the goal of
breaking down biases uh forming
emotional connection
uh with people in between people and
spurring people to take action
all right we've got an interesting
sponsor for this episode we're sponsored
by the jordan harbinger show
which is a podcast you all really should
be listening to and
i know that every day someone tells you
you have to try out this podcast
and you're like yeah that sounds great
um but then you never do it so i need
you to not do that and actually listen
to this show because it's pretty great
so apple named it one of its best in
2018
and yang jokes of this podcast has
homework um which it kind of does but
it's meant to be educational and a
really really
powerful interesting exciting way so
each episode's like a conversation with
different fascinating guests
and when i say there's something for
everyone here i mean that so one episode
jordan talks to a
hostage negotiator from the fbi who
offers technique
techniques on how to get people to like
you and trust you and another episode
talks about a cinematographer
who discovered a lost city in the jungle
and made one of the
most important like archaeological finds
of the century
so the range is crazy they're doing a
piece on a guy who was undercover in the
mob
right now there's another piece on how
not to get scammed so i've listened to
that to help my grandmother
and myself because i'm kind of prone to
that crap anyway um
it's a fascinating show i like it
because it's a good way to learn
um in an interactive way and and kind of
better yourself so
check out the jordan harbinger show
that's h-a-r-b
as in boy i n as in nancy g-e-r
that's on apple podcast spotify wherever
you listen
you guys will like this so jordan
harbinger
or the jordan harbinger show you can
find it anywhere you find podcasts
tune in
um so you and i uh worked closely
together on that documentary and if
anyone's listening to this
wants to see a feature documentary
about a group of young entrepreneurs
trying to make
positive things happen in detroit
generation startup is a phenomenal film
that i make cameos in as yoda as cheryl
said
but cheryl's the co-director and
producer
of that movie and that was a real labor
of love i learned so much from you
during the making of that film uh
and it was a lot of fun yeah
it uh i i certainly lived everything
those young entrepreneurs were living
um but it was uh
it was a lot of fun and thank you for
trusting me
andrew to take that journey together
because we so we filmed with uh
six venture for america fellows over the
course of a year and a half
and you didn't know and i didn't know
where those stories would go
but when we met uh to talk about doing
it i said to you
uh i can make a beautiful commercial for
you that you can use
for recruiting and for fundraising
or you can and you know i'll make you
are the client i'll make whatever you
want
or you can give me full access full
editorial control
and i will make a featured documentary i
promise people will laugh and they will
cry
but whatever happens along the way if a
venture for america fellow
goes off the rails or something that
happens
like that's going in the movie if we've
been following that person
and you said in your characteristic you
know
truth-seeking way that is what i want
we uh we glamorize entrepreneurship we
only hear about uh you know startup
founders when they're successful
and we need to tell the honest story the
true story
of how hard it is but also how rewarding
it can be um
and that you know uh and you never ask
me in those year and a half
what what are you recording what are you
capturing how's the film going
i mean meanwhile i was like oh my god
are we gonna have a film at the end of
this i was tracking the stories very
carefully but you don't know until you
go into edit
like is it gonna like hold together even
towards
even until the very end of the edit i
was very very worried how are we gonna
make these six disparate stories
a cohesive whole yeah it was a
daunting challenge but you pulled it off
and then some
you and the team i loved that movie and
it was
a privilege to be a part of it and you
know the fact that it touched so many
people
made me really happy it it had it was
funny because
i sell jokes that probably cut a little
close to home for you but i talk about
how like i wouldn't
uh wish uh the world of independent film
on my worst enemy
i like it right because i saw what you
went through but i just know that that's
like uh
an industry where it's got to be
people uh doing labors of love because
like
it's not like anyone's like throwing
riches generally i mean
and you know like other things you might
hear about like the one crazy outlier
uh but for the most part it's a very
very
tough field uh and it's like the spirit
of entrepreneurship that you were
containing so that
you were capturing was actually being
embodied through your filmmaking process
i mean you're one of the reasons why i
appreciate
creatives so much because just about
every creative is really an entrepreneur
in the truest sense
uh you know you have like a vision
you're trying to make something positive
happen in the world
i don't think creators get enough credit
um for this reason
uh and one thing i said on the trail a
lot was that
artists have the same impact on an
economy or community as entrepreneurs do
like if you have a group of artists move
to a town then you should
invest in real estate in that town
because the values are going to go up
the same way
as if a group of entrepreneurs moved
there
well and also your your whole push for
ubi to
enable people to uh have time and
a little time and space to pursue
creative endeavors not
to monetize them but just because it's
such an important form of of
self-expression and
getting in touch with our own selves and
our own identity but
i i was drawn to telling that story
because i had just launched my own
company and it took me decades to get up
the courage
to take that step and i was so inspired
by these young people who were
taking you know risks it's like knowing
so much less than i did
it's so at a much younger age um
so and they kept me going i mean i you
know i i looked at them and their
resilience and their
courage and i was like okay cheryl they
can do it you can keep going too you can
do it too
so um so
for folks who are trying to well a lot
of people listening to this like oh my
gosh like i would love to get into that
industry but
i think we're right now you look out
there and you have this incredibly
discerning eye and you see a lot of bad
stuff you see some good stuff
you know i mean like uh there's a lot of
um not compelling video content shall we
say
out there um so assuming that folks who
are listening to this are
creators or creatives um you've laid out
some of the big principles
around having a relatable character
who's authentic
and struggle somewhat so it could be you
the
you know the the filmmaker and subject
simultaneously or it could be you
finding someone else
uh and and then there's a degree of
struggle or adversity that they go
through which we're all kind of familiar
with the hero's journey and like you
know like
the obstacles come up and then optimally
you wind up
um with some triumphant note or at least
feeling of optimism but the triumphant
note has to feel genuine
it cannot feel pat and it has to be
like which is why in generation startup
uh that film is so powerful because we
you know
it it's hard won they all are triumphant
in but also triumphant in very
non-conventional ways some of them
which is why we uh ta the tagline for
the film is
learning to fail redefining success
um because and this is one of the big
themes in my campaign and something i'm
very passionate about is that if you do
something and you uh believed in it
and you put your heart and soul into it
and it quote unquote doesn't work out
or like you don't become rich or
something like that like
it's still incredibly rewarding
informative um
and it's a frustration of mine that we
essentially at this point
um will let others tell us what success
is
you know what i mean like uh or like
tell us what success is
well i mean that's what holds so many of
us back from doing what we really want
to do
is like even you talk about it the the
values and measures of success in our
society
um are around how much money do you make
or what is your job title or where
like what company when even when i
introduced you as an award-winning
winning filmmaker which you are
but there is like a little bit of like
this you know
joe might not have won an award and
she'd still be uh incredible and awesome
as like uh yeah everything else
yeah but but but the the the more
important thing is that
again to you know i i told you when
we started making the movie i mean i for
me it wasn't a horse race to see like
which of these companies will succeed
and who's going to do better
i mean it was all i cared about was
will these um i call them kids will
these young people they were 21 22 23
years old
will they learn will they grow and for
me that movie generation
startup is about celebrating moving
outside our comfort zone
to learn and grow to just to to to test
ourselves to see what we're capable of
and also
working hard to make um our communities
stronger and to
to to lift up others along with us so
for for me that movie isn't was never
about
um success in the conventional sense and
everyone in that film they all learned
and grew so
much i mean in terms of measuring your
success
you know when you started out everyone
thought you were nuts andrew and
longer than a little bit cheryl no one
told me
oh well and then you know in terms of
success i mean you made it first of all
you made it much further than anyone
would have ever bet but also your
what you were trying to do was make the
things you cared about that you saw that
most others didn't see part of our um
you know open open our eyes to what was
happening in the country and you also
wanted to normalize this idea of a
freedom dividend or human
you know universal basic income which
now
you know you were so prescient about all
of that so
you succeeded in a big way and now you
have
a lot of exposure that you're using to
drive humanity forward
so i would call you know even though
you're not our presidential
candidate i mean i would call your run
and
tremendous success well thank you cheryl
you were a big part of it
and certainly you helped in day one by
making
uh what i thought was a very well done
clever resourceful video
given what we had i want to say if
people are listening to this and they're
thinking of hiring me do not use that
video as the benchmark for what i'm
capable of
that's all i want to say um
well you know they can look up your work
and they can take their pick certainly
i you know i agree like that video
like she had nothing right i'm very
little
footage and just made it happen but i i
thought that that video was like a
crucial part of our
having any launch at all because even
when i because i you know i i'm
like i was trying to plan my
presidential launch and i was like what
do i need at a bare minimum
i need a website i need a piece of press
like something kind of credible and i
need
a snappy campaign video and then if i
don't have those three things then
like i should not even call myself an
entrepreneur
so you were the third leg of the stool
very much so
um because i thought you made a very
snappy campaign video with very limited
material
it at least was snappy it was definitely
and it wasn't cheesy
it wasn't cheesy so even if some of the
license footage was
uh but yes
all right guys i am so excited to share
with you a brand new limited documentary
podcast that is sponsoring yank speaks
and this podcast series is called it was
said and we highly recommend it so the
series will move you it's
inspirational for sure and it's uh i'm
gonna call it a muslis in
in covid so what it is is the ten
episode documentary podcast
it's a limited series and explores and
brings to life ten of the most historic
speeches in american history and what's
cool about it
is that it was said was written and
narrated by pulitzer prize winning
and best-selling author historian this
guy named john meacham
and then is created by the peabody
nominated c13 original studios these
guys know what they're doing
and they're partnering with history so
it's freaking fascinating they cover
some of the most timeless and impactful
speeches in american history so you're
going to have
people on this it was said podcasts like
martin luther king jr and ronald reagan
and jfk and john lewis and edward murrow
and barbara jordan and more and puts you
in these moments in time that are still
relevant
frankly and important today so meacham
the host offers this kind of expert
insights and analysis into their origins
of the speech and so the orator and the
context and the times they were given
and frankly why they still matter today
and why it's important we never forget
them so each episode this documentary
will bring together some of the top
historians and authors and journalists
to give more context to each speech
and frankly the inspiration behind it
and explaining
why that was the case so it was said is
now available for you to subscribe and
listen for free
on apple podcast spotifyradio.com and
wherever
you listen to podcasts so check it out
it was said for you history buffs or
just
curious people like me or andrew that
find this stuff fascinating
tune in
one reason why i always admired you so
much and we bonded over this is that you
just seem like such an amazing
parent uh to me having met uh your kids
now and you know they're in their 20s a
lot older than mine
um but you had such empathy for them too
and they've become such fully formed
interesting fascinating creative adults
uh and that was something i always
admired about you a great deal like i
hope to live up to your example on that
front i'm sure you are andrew i'm sure
you are but again
i don't know you said a high bar cheryl
like your kids are
freaking phenomenal not to say you know
that's not again the measurement but
like you know you you just seem like
such a
loving uh warm empathetic understanding
parent
thank you you know what i think that uh
enlightened leadership enlightened
parenting and you know it all boils down
to
the all the same qualities that i bring
to storytelling
um and it's about
engaged active listening really
listening to
our children and not trying to control
them
um letting them be who they are and
having compassion or empathy for what
they're going through
you know if if a child is throwing a
temper tantrum
it's very easy to as a parent to get
very frustrated but i think the
important thing is to have compassion
for the child and try to understand
what's causing that temper tantrum you
know and then
just um being very real and um
and teaching them like i i try to teach
them to trust their gut and to hone
their values
and i i you know from a very young age
if they would come to me
to work through something i would just
ask them a lot of
open-ended questions to try to mirror
back to them how they were feeling
and help them navigate and figure out
what they wanted
um i i you know my husband and i we
never
tried to tell them who they should be or
what they should do
and i did say to them i said you know we
don't expect you to do everything well
but don't half-ass the things that
matter to you yeah
just commit yourself to doing whatever
you do i mean i think that yeah
and do that well i mean but i i'm most
proud of them andrew for
the people they are for their values for
their caring
their you know their high you know such
such strong values um and
yeah so i i'm much more i'm i'm proud of
them for who they are as
as people not for their accomplishments
which are
theirs not mine well there is so
there's so much that people could take
from really even what seems like
relatively simple
principles around parenting and
leadership you know i think
that degree of listening to people
and letting folks discover things for
themselves and also
trusting them yes you know i think
there's a lot we could learn from that
you know like that like you you are uh
so let's say there's one extreme and you
know and the caricature of me actually
embodies this extreme though though
you're one person that
always uh you know pooh-poohed the
caricature which i appreciated
um so i could pull all characters i
poopoo all stereotypes
but yes so like if you have on on one
side let's call it like the
facts figures like uh math
hyper rationality data driven
uh you know calculating and then on the
other
side you have like a human emotional
empathetic caring
stories and the rest of it and and the
caricature of me is obviously all the
way over here
um you you've always uh said like no
andrew you're actually like much more
human
and then i would sort of make some
self-deprecating joke about being like
the robotic asian guy or
whatever it happens to be uh and
um you know i i think that that there's
so much to be taken
from your point of view really and it's
something that our country is struggling
with in a very real way where you could
also
if you wanted and this is a
generalization obviously but you could
like you know put the gender poles
um uh where when you talked about being
the second in command who helped
build these various enterprises like
like at least for me i heard it's like i
have a feeling there are a lot of women
who hear that or like yeah like that's
the way it is in my department or that
that's the way it is like a particular
um you know like they look up at their
their management team they they see that
sort of dynamic
um like i i think that
that our economy in my opinion is
becoming increasingly
inhuman and punitive and like veering
off to like uh this rightward
direction uh and my big goal is to try
and humanize it
um and i feel like what you're doing
with this human-centered storytelling is
trying to drag us
in this direction um in a positive way
i feel like the world needs much much
more of it the world would use like
could use like a legion of cheryl
hauser's even though that's impossible
because
you're like this unique um figure and
and unicorn and one of my goals and
having this conversation really was for
you to try and impart some of what makes
you
you want to like other folks who want to
be you and i know there are many people
listening to this are watching this who
are thinking like wow this woman's
amazing
um so yeah that that just wanted to lay
out that that was like the
um the impossible goal i'd set
for myself for this conversation yeah
but andrew you that's my profound
gratitude for
um everything you've done and who you
are
oh well i feel the same about you andrew
you know that
but and and you know you say the
character of you
is you know maybe that like you know the
math guy
but we all know that's not who you are i
mean why
did you you you you risked so much and
you you know you left your family for
two years and you
like went on on this campaign trail
because you
you had a calling you were driven
because you were so
empathetic to what you saw happening in
our country
so you you engaged your big brain to see
look at the data
and see what was happening but then you
engaged your big heart
to say i see what's happening and i
can't let it happen i have to take
action
and in your taking action you stirred
everyone else to follow you in
solidarity
to change what's happening and that's
what i try to do with storytelling
um the same thing to to create action
and solidarity but you know
you ask in your book and your your
slogan was humanity first and now your
humanity forward and
in your book you ask what makes us human
what makes us human is our ability to
love
to feel to care to have empathy to feel
empathy
and you know um in all of the you know
there's this
this guy um paul zack who's done a ton
of studies in the lab around
storytelling and around the oxytocin and
the cortisol
but he you know one of his studies he
would play a video of a father talking
to up to the camera about his son
who's two and dying of cancer and um
and uh it it follows that hero's journey
of this
of this the father's i have to be strong
for him and then at the end
and he he's uh taking people's oxytocin
the beginning the end
you know cortisol of that at the end of
that story he asks do you want to
donate some of the money you're being
paid to be in this study
to a charity that gives money to um
for children with cancer and
the higher levels of oxytocin that
people have in their blood
uh indicated they would give more money
i mean it's
and then the people who did give money
felt warm and fuzzy after giving the
money
and the people who didn't didn't which
we also know that
when we give we benefit so much so this
is what
like i want to move people in telling
stories
to have the warm and fuzzy feeling and
then you know and to be
fired up to take action um and you say
it all the time
you know and which is why you talk about
like how dire things are but you also
give everyone hope you have a vision of
what society could be
if we can tap into our humanity and tap
into and get that oxytocin flowing and
get the you know
more of the optimism and the love and
the caring
and empathy and all of those things
so it you know it is it is a self
like love begets love hope begets hope
and we know when people are hopeful and
optimistic what they're capable of they
can start to take risk and
um see their potential and reach for
their potential
if people have the men's uh uh mentality
of scarcity as you talk about
their all they can think about is like
survival
it's survival mode and then you can't
think about
caring for others and loving others and
all those other things
so anyway i mean there is a corollary
between what you're trying to do in
politics
and what i try to do with storytelling
um
then it all comes down to humanity and
what makes us
human and bringing out the humanity in
us
because that's when we are our best
selves
now that makes me really proud that you
think we're doing the same kind of work
cheryl it makes me very happy
um you know it is about dialing up
humanity
um i have a question for you that i
don't know if we've ever discussed this
really but when i i told you i was
running for president and i said hey
when you make this
campaign video like what did you really
think
um i remember i'll never forget the
moment when you told me you were running
for president we were at
um an event screening at grand central
tech
and um it was you had just
uh sold your book the war on normal
people you hadn't started to write the
war on normal people
and um the people were watching the
movie and whenever
uh we were at these event screenings
together when people watched the movie
it was a time for us to catch up which
was wonderful
and you said i'm going to run for
president and you know what
i said to you what i have would say to
my children when they told me they were
going to do things that sounded kind of
crazy
i said that's amazing i said andrew
go for it first of all because i knew
you well by then and i saw how you had
built venture for america
so fast and i knew that you more than
anyone
i've ever met can will things into being
and this is also storytelling
the stories we tell ourselves either
propel us
or hold us back so you know
um we filmed with cassandra who was born
a congenital amputee
and her whole life told herself and
other people told her
you only have one arm you cannot be a
nurse she wanted to be a nurse
she was told you cannot be a nurse you
only have one arm
and then when she got onto social media
and um saw that there were other people
with one arm who were nurses
if you can't see it you can't be it she
realized wow
i can be a nurse and when she told
herself i can be a nurse
she figured out how to make that happen
you are someone who tells yourself i am
going to do this
i can do this and then you make it
happen you just
will it into existence and that is also
the power of storytelling the stories we
tell ourselves
and so when you said i'm going to run
for president
i thought okay it's crazy but andrew is
he's going to do it i mean i i didn't
think you were going to be our candidate
but i
did think that you were going to make a
lot of noise and that you were going to
reach your goal
of making universal basic income and
automation and all the things and uh
you know looking at a different way to
measure
progress in our in our society that you
were going to make them
part of the public you know discourse
um throughout the campaign and onwards
and and so it
you know you really have done that and
you continue to do that through humanity
forward which is
and yang speaks and everything you're
doing so
um again what did i think i thought this
is so bold this is so crazy
if anyone can pull off success whatever
success is going to look like it's
andrew if anyone has the guts to do this
it's andrew and when you call when i
remember when you asked me to do the
video
you called you got my voicemail and you
left a message and you said hey cheryl
it's andrew calling
i have a favor to ask can you call me
back and i knew it's like okay
andrew wants me to make his campaign i
knew it
i just knew it and i thought i
am honored i would be honored that's
what i thought i am drew
well well you definitely delivered you
know you called back and said yeah let's
do it which i was endlessly grateful for
because uh you didn't have much to work
with and like we weren't paying top
dollar or anything close to it
it was it was just a yet another labor
of love
um and i hope you felt proud of
everything that happened
thereafter because genuinely think that
uh it might not have happened if not for
your belief in friendships
so thank you wow it would have happened
but i was honored to be part of that
journey and to be part of helping
you know you uh you start the campaign
i mean yeah uh yeah
so um so if anyone wants to see your
work uh where should they go
uh well uh they should go to
creativebreed.com
and i have to update it because some of
my recent work isn't there
but um and generation startup is
generationstartup.com and we were on
netflix for two years as you know
no longer but we're still on itunes
amazon google play
youtube voodoo hoopla 2b
i mean generation startup is widely
available um and still moving people
you should know my cousin sent me a
picture
of my face on the monitor of the
airplane seat in front of her because
she was watching
your movie on a plane being like hey
look
look at this so the movie generation
startup is indeed everywhere
and i'm sure it is uh moving people um
all over the world still
to this day and you know um we're just
getting started
uh there are so many stories to tell and
we we do have to do everything we can to
try and humanize
this land right now because it needs you
more than ever so thank you for
everything cheryl and
i and and thank you for helping make me
more human
i genuinely had your voice in my ear the
entire campaign
where like i was like you know what
cheryl would say
cheryl would be like andrew you know you
just have to try to
um express your humanity so you should
know you had a big impact on me
thank you i think i think it was the
natural evolution
but i apprecia i hear you and i and i
appreciate
the thanks but um you know watching you
for me that was so i what i was most
proud of
i mean just to see you grow and
evolve um you know you were always
incredibly human
so it wasn't like you weren't human and
you became human
it's just you allowed yourself to
express that more
and more and more you know as you and
now you know
i think you're you like you just are so
comfortable
in that in that thing in place well
thank you we have to
unlock and uh elevate people's humanity
i feel like you know in a way what you
saw with me i think
um we need to activate in more people um
you know uh like that process
and i think i genuinely think our
economy and our culture have put
us many of us in boxes where people just
feel like they have like a
narrow role to fill or like a narrow set
of things they can express
uh and that if you can let them out of
that box
uh then the sky's the limit i feel like
that that's what your work's about
um but yeah like it's i learned a lot uh
and we are just getting started as you
said
and you're gonna be there every step of
the way i'm gonna call you next time now
but this time we'd you know have more to
work with i'm sure
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]
you